on April sorry we're going to be going
to the final round of the international
competition collegiate hello icca for
sure basically if you've seen pitch
perfect it's literally it's literally
that competition for the top ten groups
will be performing at the Beacon Theater
yeah and it's an amazing opportunity and
just a great honor to be even considered
one of the top ten groups and actually
it's crazy do you can think about it but
yeah we're really excited for that I'm
April thirtieth we have a fan club from
Carnegie Mellon's a lot of people are
going to be coming in so I'm really
excited I think it's it's written as if
this is finals was something we have
only guests arrive before like it was so
far away for us like three years ago so
my freshman year we was the first
he admits his semi-finals yeah and so
that was like already a huge impress me
and finals was this like it's like
during a far-off like awesome landscape
that like it was just like a complete
pipe dream for us like it would never
have right where some of us Oh what if
things and it's just it's just insane to
believe it now let's actually have class
cheering up for that our 70s and we lost
our minds yeah yeah to begin first for
our region and we alighted and it's such
like oh we're experienced coming into
this group since I'm freshman and only
being here for one year in order
amazing honor it's it blew my mind that
we could just do something like this I I
wasn't expecting this at all joining
this crew I really just wanted to come
and sing and it's really cool that our
work is paying off